I want to spend just a second talking
about how fantastic our reddit
discussion forum has gone this started
with the help of a couple of viewers
maybe like a year or so ago and it's now
grown to close to 2,000 different
viewers who are part of our reddit
discussion forum which you can access by
going to david pakman.com slash read it
yes there is trolling on our reddit
discussion forum but that it's read it I
mean that's just sort of to be expected
but there are also some really great
ideas discussions interview suggestions
that are coming from the audience on
reddit I'll just go through a couple of
them with you here here is one
discussion about the term sjw social
justice warrior which at the time we
took this screenshot had six comments
but it has grown to 30 40 or 50 comments
some trolling but really pretty good
discussions of the way in which this
term has sort of become an insult on the
internet the fact that there's really
nothing bad about wanting social justice
but sort of some of the more extreme
views that have sometimes been included
under this umbrella and just sort of the
optics of the term really a pretty good
discussion you just have to skip over a
few instances of trolling messages but I
think anybody who spends time on the
Internet is sort of used to that
here's another discussion from our
reddit discussion forum this one a
little more bizarre this is someone
suggesting that I am actually an Android
and they're using basically the fact
that there's a very small glitch during
one of the advertisements that plays on
the show and also that the show is maybe
that I've been replaced by a bot of some
kind I don't know that this is a serious
suggestion but it's certainly funny
nonetheless here's another discussion
from our reddit discussion forum what
does David Pakman and his fans okay find
the grammar is atrocious but it's still
a legitimate question what do David
Pakman and his fans think of dave rubin
and this actually became a very very
good discussion about how the left has
sort of become fragmented in some ways
and you have those in the sort of social
I'm sorry civil libertarian area of the
left that
sometimes identifying more with the
policies of the Libertarian Party and
sort of the ways in which X Republicans
and X Democrats sometimes unite around a
lot of shared libertarian ideas although
not all very good discussion that I
would love it if you participated in
let's look at a couple of others here
this was just a total goof after last
week we did our durian
tasting in studio in the middle of the
night a user who goes by the name of
gigantic meaty balls went on and posted
a picture of durian saying quick the
mods are asleep post durians and that's
absolutely fine I like it anything
related to the show is cool and then I
think we have one more here Jason the
truth about police shooting black men
this was a longer analysis of our video
discussing these statistics about the
racial aspect of the shooting of black
men in the United States and really a
very good discussion took place so I
know sometimes people email me Jason and
they say David you know I get that
reddit is cool now these days with the
kids or whatever but I can't deal with
the trolling on reddit so I'm not part
of your discussion forum there I find it
and now that you're checking out the
reddit forum every day it's pretty easy
to just ignore the trolling and just
check out what are really some pretty
good political discussions on there I
think you know there's there's always
love with hate and hate is actually love
and the fact that they think you Hillary
and Rubio are are Androids of the same
manufacturer I think that's just pure
love and we're the laughs please
subscribe to our reddit discussion forum
david pakman.com slash read it you will
be redirected to our reddit discussion
forum and i participate on their almost
daily so it's a really really good way
to get your ideas to me too